[Music]
chuck
hey so chuck how do you know how big big
something is
yeah measure you measure it right so you
pull out a ruler let's say let's say
it's a table
and you measure it okay so there are two
things working against you on that
one of them is you know how close
together are the
the hash lines
on the ruler
right right because if your table ends
up between two of them
then you don't know how long your table
is you you if you're gonna report to me
you can only say it's between here and
there and
venture guess to where it is from one
marker to the next okay so it's kind of
like half maybe what you'll you'll give
me a guess fine but you won't know
exactly because you don't have the
metrics to determine that right nobody's
measuring in in hands
[Laughter]
he's seven hands tall
really that's awesome
well hands is actually a specific
measurement i mean i think the hand is
four inches oh really the width of your
hand uh yeah look at that i see and i
just learned something there horse
heights are measured in hand in hands
right i knew that their horses were
measured in hands but i didn't know that
that hand had an actual unit it's around
four inches don't don't quote me on that
but that's yeah yeah okay okay
okay so even if you had the precision
to measure the length of the table
if you go down under a microscope
like a really good microscope like an
electron microscope that's the kind of
microscopes where you see all of the
hairs on the on the on the bugs and you
know you see the eyeballs of the fly
those kind of microscopes if you do that
you'll see that the edge of the table is
not smooth
it's actually got texture
so which feature of the texture are you
going to measure it to and then report
back to me the width of the table
well
what happens is at some point you just
give up and say neil i can't you're
annoying or anything right you can't you
can't measure anything unless you just
agree
you just agree
how are you going to take the
measurement and then you're good with
that well
if you have that problem with solid
objects
imagine the challenge
measuring the extent of gaseous objects
just imagine that okay yes i believe you
measure that and how bad it smells
[Laughter]
not all gas came out of your rear end
okay in this world just saying
so you can ask how high up does the
atmosphere go
well so you ascend and you see is there
a sign that says you are now leaving
earth's atmosphere
no
no
the atmosphere gets
continually thinner
right and you know this because as you
ascend a mountain
the air pressure drops
it's harder for you to breathe you can
still breathe but just every lungs worth
of air has less oxygen in it
okay that's your evidence that the air
pressure is getting lower and lower and
lower should have never smoked man
god this is killing me
this continues you go into an airplane
airplanes are pressurized right which
means they put air in there otherwise
you would suffocate if they open if you
roll down the windows all right so those
oxygen masks those are there in case the
airplane loses pressure
and your breathing very low density air
has hardly any oxygen in it so you gotta
breathe through the mask that's all okay
by the way you could hold your breath
until you did this i mean this is not
you're not going to die immediately you
have to fight for them just it's just
air okay right you've held
breath-holding contests for longer than
the time it'll take you to reach for one
of these yellow masks
and remember people always put your own
mask on first before you try to put the
mask on that of a child
so
which by the way no one had to tell me
okay
like when i when i heard that i was just
like and and what else would i have done
okay
chuck was first out of the box on that
one actually i was like i was like this
kid ain't bringing nothing to the table
[Laughter]
really
i might i might just let the kid pass
out just so i can get some rest
oh that was the noisy kid you're not
giving him the oxygen
wait let's not be so quick there mom
that kid is looking real peaceful right
now
all right that's cold all right oh by
the way it's also literally cold as you
leave earth's surface
because you're farther away from the
heat point of
the heat generating point which is the
well that that's another
scratch that another explainer another
okay so as you ascend the air just
simply gets thinner and thinner and
thinner
there is no spot where you say it ends
here and and it's space there's no there
isn't
so you just have to agree
on what that altitude will be
pick a thing
and then just you go are you good with
that i'm good with that fine put it in
the books move on to the next problem
okay okay so there's a guy in the 1960s
named carmen
okay
he was hungarian i think but worked in
the united states
and he said there must be an altitude
above which the atmosphere is no longer
scattering sunlight
above your head
so that it's no longer sky blue
the blue goes away and then you just see
stars
in broad daylight oh wow that's an
interesting threshold right that is and
that's there'll still be air molecules
there just not enough
to scatter because that's how you get a
blue sky it scatters the blue of
sunlight and now the sky is glowing and
you can't see the night sky
you can't see stars in the daytime sky
so because it's daytime however if you
ascend high enough in the atmosphere
there's a point where there aren't many
molecules above you bada bing the sun is
still there but you can see stars
in addition to our own star
in the sky so that's called a carmen
line
and ever since the early 60s the karman
line has been the functional definition
of a transition into space whether or
not you were in earth orbit
interesting our first astronaut alan
shepard went up in 1961 he went into
lo he went to um suborbital
was fished out of the atlantic okay
and
uh he went high enough to go above the
karman line so that counted and so
that's sort of our astronaut threshold
carmen himself however knew
that the atmosphere is not some rigid
thing it's gas right and sometimes it
heats up sometimes it cools down so it
will expand it will shrink and so so
those the carbon line is not itself a
definite thing
but if you're going to look for it it
would you'd find it between
anywhere between 80
85 and 100 kilometers okay that would
convert to 53 to 62 miles up
somewhere in there okay and so so to say
did you hit this exact point or not
that's like arguing you know which which
edge of the table are you using to give
me the length of the table
except worse because it's gas
right
so
uh point is the atmosphere continues out
for thousands of miles
oh no
yeah in fact wow the international space
station which is 200
miles up
right two
how much higher than the 62 mile carbon
line is it's four times higher than the
carbon line the international space
station is huge it's like the size of a
football field
moving through the air there's enough
atmospheric molecules up there
to hit the solar panels and the physical
body to to to
drop it to lower orbits than you than
you had originally intended
so every now and then the space station
has to boost itself up
back to the to its original target orbit
because of the air molecules that hit it
that's insane yes
and that's 250 miles up
so there is no edge
and if you're going to ask me what is
the diameter of the sun you could look
this up in a book you you could look
this up the the diameter of the sun
it'll give it to you
and you say well wait a minute the sun
is made of gas
so how precisely are you measuring did
you take a ruler and do that
not only that
you could say in what wavelength of
light did you measure the diameter of
the sun
do you know different wavelengths of
light
emanate from different locations within
the depth of the sun
if you if you're like jordy on on star
trek next generations and you look at
the sun in ultraviolet light
it has a different dimension
from what it has if you look at it in
visible light and if you look at it in
infrared light
then if you look at it in x-rays
all different dimensions in fact the
solar corona the thing that's glowing
outside of the the moon when you see the
total solar eclipse that's called the
corona which is latin for crown so
sensibly right so so if you look at that
with x-rays that's the size of the sun
forget the down on the sun's surface
gaseous surface x-rays the corona is
ablaze with light and you're gonna say
the sun is huge so i just want to say
just want to put it out there
that
the the dimensions of things
is really just something you have to
agree to in advance
and then you all agree you put it in the
book and then you move on
so the diameter of the sun is the
diameter it shows to us using yellow
light which is right in the middle of
the visible spectrum
that's the number you're going to read
in the book
but they'll tell you that but i'm
telling you that i'm glad you did cause
uh it's good to know they've been lying
to me all night
oh by the way and you can think of other
definitions of space i got one for you
are you ready so airplanes use fuel
it's called with aviation fuel there's a
word for it i forgot anyway it uses fuel
so fuel our common understanding of fuel
is you burn it and then energy you get
energy
but what does it mean to burn it
it means it gets attached to the oxygen
molecule
creates a third other product right
there's that molecule the oxygen
molecule they
merge and make they make this other
molecule and it's exothermic
energy gets generated okay
that's how cars work that's how
airplanes work
but where's it getting its oxygen from
the atmosphere
okay
wait a minute but if you're a rocket
and you're going to where there is no
oxygen where there's not much oxygen you
got to bring your own oxidizer
you can't depend on the atmosphere so
you so you could say
i you enter space
at an altitude where an airplane can't
get enough oxygen to fly anymore
and it just drops out of the sky that's
an interesting threshold
you could have done it that way because
above that you need a rocket
and we all know rockets equals space
okay there you go i can think of 10
other ways you might define it
but i'm just i'm just saying
just
numbers and measurements of things are
not
they're not written in tablets
they're you have to agree on what it is
you're trying to measure write down that
number and then move on
there you go measurements not written in
tablets only commandments
[Laughter]
all right that's all we got time for all
right yeah that's a crazy subject but i
have to put it out there yeah that's
very cool that's and when you hear
people arguing over the karman line just
sit back and chuckle and say the karma
line is an idea more than is an actual
place within earth's atmosphere well if
i ever get into an uh argument about the
karman line my answer will be
so how big is the sun
and also the hundred kilometer karman
line did you really think the atmosphere
is layered into even
evenly divisible numbers in kilometers
did you really think that's the
case if you look up caramelizes 100
kilometers yeah the earth is like tight
with the with the with the metric people
right
it's like no 100 is well above whatever
carmen was talking about but if you want
to round it up you round it up to 100
kilometers and that's the definition
fine okay and the american definition is
lower than that we're like at 85
kilometers up we have a lower definition
than europe and the rest of the world do
oh well yeah that's that's because you
know we want to be able to say we went
to space we want to be able to say that
that allen shepard wants to separate
with the space correct exactly we're the
first people to do it you know right
right right it's just like uh we uh we
put a spire on top of uh the freedom
tower and it's like now the tallest
building in the country
exactly yeah
that's all right dude all right man good
stuff
dark talk
explainer stuff you thought you knew
always good to have you check neil
degrasse tyson here keep looking up
[Music]